[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur figaro
live on est désolé on est très très
heureux de vous retrouver on n'est pas
des élus et de vous retrouver mais on
est très très heureux de vous retrouver
on est désolé pour les annulations
inopinée de la semaine dernière nous
vous présentons toutes nos excuses et
vous nous avez manqué on est vraiment
très content de vous avoir pour débattre
ce soir de la réponse que la france doit
donner à au pays et qui boycotte ces
produits à commencer par la turquie mais
il y en a bien d'autres
on attend on attend vos points de vue et
on va aller partager ce soir avec
nicolas baverez
bonsoir nicolas bonsoir avocat essayiste
chroniqueur également au figaro la
dernière chronique de nicolas en date
eh bien vous la trouvez dans le figaro
dans l'édition papier du figaro
d'aujourd'hui et c'est une chronique sur
la chine comment la chine est en train
de profiter de la pandémie et que la
propager et de la mondialisation du
confinement s'est retrouvé également sur
vous le voyez le site du figaro face à
nicolas est avec nous ce soir avec vous
aussi alexandre ii vecchio bonsoir
alexandre on ne cesse de recommander
recomposition avec les nouveaux mondes
populiste le dernier livre d'alexandre
ii vecchio aux éditions du cerf et votre
interview également tout près de celle
de la chronique de nicolas votre
interview de marcel gaucher a retrouvé
là aussi dans l'édition papier du figaro
de ce lundi est également sur le site du
figaro à côté de ces deux tribus à côté
de ces deux papiers de cette interview
de cette tribune
il y a une autre tribune et il ya signé
d'olivier fort rien à voir avec le
patron du parti socialiste ou ce qu'il
en reste
mais olivier faure c'est un historien de
la santé et il
demande à ce qu'on arrête de tancer les
français alors faut-il arrêter de
culpabiliser les français sur la
propagation sur leur comportement face à
la propagation de la cofidis 9
êtes vous d'accord n'êtes vous pas
d'accord là aussi en débat mais d'abord
d'abord d'abord revenons à la dernière
escalade diplomatique l'appel au boycott
de plusieurs produits français dans
plusieurs pays du maghreb et du machrek
surtout du machrek c'est à dire de ce
qu'on appelle le moyen-orient
officiellement pour cette petite phrase
prononcée la semaine dernière lors de
l'hommage à samuel pâtit par emmanuel
macron nous défendrons la liberté que
vous enseignez si bien et nous porterons
haut à la laïcité
nous ne renoncerons pas aux caricatures
au dessin même si d'autres reculs alors
celui qui s'est distingué dans les
réactions parfois outrancière dans ce
domaine c'est encore une fois tout
seigneur tout honneur le président turc
hier il demandait à ce qu'on examine la
santé mentale des manuels macron
aujourd'hui il s'en prend à l'économie
française
chim d'ébène boulot 2010 mais c'est nul
n'ose alquier al-assad à tout marquage
est mort certaine mind your sa main des
cimes du bourdon humilité mais c'est nul
ça qu'une française marc allard à auzat
il fat et bim mais la route est longue
alors la france a répliqué avec le
rappel de son ambassadeur à ankara
voici également ce qu en pense une autre
personnalité importante dans ce domaine
le représentant le responsable du
patronat français le patron du medef
geoffroy roux de bézieux
bien sûr c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
pour les entreprises qui sont implantées
là bas dans l'agroalimentaire dans le
luxe dans les cosmétiques mais il n'est
pas question de céder au chantage
il ya un moment on doit faire passer les
principes avant la possibilité de
développer nos affaires et donc on est
évidemment totalement solidaire du
gouvernement français et moi évidemment
j'appelle les entreprises à résister à
ce chantage mais est malheureusement à
subir
alors malheureusement à suivre cette
situation alexandre pardon mais deux
personnalités que vous méprisez guerre
emmanuel macron et le représentant du
patronat français ont eu la bonne
réaction en tout cas celle que vous
prisé je ne sais pas si j'ai quelque
chose contre geoffroy roux de bézieux je
suis pas toujours d'accord avec les
positions du medef mais il peut en avoir
aussi des bonnes en tout cas je pense
que fx et leur fils emmanuel macron a
bien réagi et geoffroy roux de bézieux
ont bien réagi effectivement tous les
deux nicolas votre point de vue est ce
que c'est une bonne réaction de la part
du président français du président du
medef
bien sûr mais ce sont des réactions de
court terme je crois que ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est la configuration
stratégique c'est-à-dire que le on a en
face de nous richie père de gamme donc
d'ailleurs une partie de ce qu'il a dit
est typique de ces hommes forts et de
ses dirigeants populistes puisque c'est
des mensonges avérés
personne n'a pour l'instant appelé à
boycotter des marques le turc est donc
il est en train de construire d'essayer
de pousser sa posture de meilleur
représentant du monde musulman avec la
volonté prendre le leadership du monde
arabo-musulman et de déclasser l'arabie
saoudite et l egypte pour cela donc il
ya une escalade militaire qu'on a vu en
syrie qu'on a vu en libye qu'on voit
aujourd'hui au haut karabakh
il ya une escalade dans l'agressivité
vis-à-vis de l'europe et notamment
vis-à-vis de la france c'est ce que je
voudrais rappeler c'est que la france
est une cible privilégiée pourquoi parce
que ça n'est pas n'importe quel pays par
son histoire par les valeurs qu'elle
défend la laïcité par ses engagements
contre les islamistes
elle est extrêmement et par le fait qu'
elle prône un islam qui soit compatible
avec les règles de la démocratie
et chez nous les règles de la république
elle est une cible privilégiée et
dernière chose il faut quand même faire
attention pourquoi parce que erdogan ou
temps évidemment un piège c'est à dire
que le piège que le président de la
république à éviter c'est que il faut
être enfin on est sorti du déni
vis-à-vis des islamistes mais il faut
être très clair la liberté de conscience
est les parfaits et la laïcité sont
parfaitement compatibles avec
l'exercice normal du culte et avec la
foi religieuse dès lors qu'elle est
exercée de manière paisible et en
conformité avec les lois de la
république donc on voit que ce sont les
affidés de la turquie c'est à dire le
qatar un certain nombre d'extrémistes du
extrémistes du hamas qui s'inscrivent
dans la configuration d'orience des
frères musulmans
voilà et qui sont est évidemment
derrière art hogan une fois encore je
vous donne la parole
alexandre mais je la donne tout de suite
à nos internautes qui sont nombreux déjà
réagir d'abord sur erdogan l'ena nous
dit erdogan a sûrement oublié qu'on
insulte pas un chef d etat qu entre gens
civilisés en le traitant de malade
mental
j'admire macron qui ne s'est pas
rabaisser à son niveau le traitant de
dictateur et christ christophe nous dit
nous avons été lâche en achetant erdogan
il sait qu'il mène le jeu et nous
imposera ce qu'il veut oui on peut
parler de la lâcheté de l'europe on va
héros bien j'ai juste un petit point
c'est l'allusion faite je pense à la
question migratoire et odile qui avait
dépassé plus exactement entre l'angola
merkel et avec le dr daud gaye sur la
question des migrants il va et venez on
va venir je voudrais juste un point 2-2
sémantique avec mon ami nicolas de
l'adresse france qui va être d'accord
mais je pense qu'ils se il s'est trompé
quand il a il a parlé de populiste à
l'égard de erdogan on ne peut pas mettre
sur le même plan erdogan qui est
clairement aujourd'hui un dictateur
islamiste s'est pas reprendre au décor
c'est pas la même chose là la turquie
n'a pas la même histoire que les états
unis en aux états unis à tous les coups
trop contre-pouvoirs démocratiques sont
en place même si donald trump se bat
contre un pouvoir des juges qui jugent
excessif
on n'a pas le poids de l'islam radical
en aux états unis erdogan après
mon coup d'état raté de l'armée en a
profité pour mettre en prison il a le
record d'emprisonnement dont rooney
scolaire devient une démocrature à la
limite je gagnais le meilleur ami de
trump erdogan et le jourdain les lieux
les deux ont un point commun ils croient
au roi rapport de force
contrairement à nous nous effectivement
on s'est mis le goûter nous pas
spécialement la france pour le coup
puisqu'elle emmanuel macron est rentré
dans un rapport de gaulle ou de force
avec erdogan et il a raison mais jeudi
l'union européenne on a vu la réaction
extrêmement tardive de l'allemagne et
des partenaires européens est
extrêmement timide alors qu'elle avait
l'occasion d'être solidaires avec la
france on a cédé au chantage des ragots
logan sur la question de l'immigration
mais aussi parce qu'on n'a plus la
maîtrise de nos frontières à l'échelle
européenne allant de la maîtrise
finalement de notre politique migratoire
puisqu'on l'a mis entre la main d edel
entre les mains des juges donc là là à
mon avis et le débat alors justement
c'est le débat qui est la question qui
est posée par par christian est
justement est-ce que erdogan profitent
de notre faiblesse et en particulier
enfin d'une faiblesse supposée qu'on
aurait eu en faisant le deal de 2016 en
examen sur de donner six milliards
d'euros qu'on en fait il faut jamais de
l'ovaire dogan neuneu n'ouvre pas ses
frontières qu'on n'ait pas une nouvelle
projet mais ils sont estimés le même
temps le l'intelligence politique de ces
jean populiste qu'est-ce que quelle est
l'analyse d'erdogan c'est de se dire
qu'il se trouve qu'il a une excellente
relation personnelle avec donald trump
et qu'à cause de l'otan il a pour
l'instant l'impunité parce que la
turquie est un actif stratégie de trop
important pour les américains
donc premièrement et qu'en plus les
etats-unis se retire du moyen-orient
deuxièmement il joue évidemment sur la
faiblesse de l'europe
vous savez churchill avait une très
bonne phrase sur l'apaisement t il
définissait la politique de l'apaisement
il disait cela revient à nourrir un
crocodile en espérant qu'ils vous
mangera an dernier et c'est exactement
ce que l'europe a fait jusqu'à présent
avec erdogan
il ya eu de multiples occasions son
agressivité extrême le fait qu'il est en
train de tenter de réussir la mise et
les balkans la crise des réfugiés on a
beaucoup de choses donc maintenant c'est
vrai qu'il faut sortir de cette
politique et qu'il faut réagir et c'est
très important pourquoi aussi parce que
même si la france et sur des positions
justes
en même temps il faut il et éviter que
la france soit seule phase rien ne
serait pire que d'avoir la france contre
une partie du monde musulman parce qu'il
n'est pas du tout ni notre intérêt ni ce
que nous souhaitons faire donc il est
très important que l'europe viennent en
appui d'une certaine manière si trump
est battue ça va faciliter les choses
parce que là dessus sans doute biden
aura une politique qui sera plus
raisonnable
en tout cas je crois que la proximité
personnelle de baden et de erdogan
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on est à
redouter
contrairement à ce qui s'est passé avec
trump et donc l'europe doit rentrer
maintenant dans une mécanique très clair
vis-à-vis de la turquie pour dire que si
ce genre de choses continuent les
agressions à méditerranée les
manipulations des réfugiés eh bien il
faut entrer dans une politique de
sanctions sanctions contre la turquie
sanctions contre ces valeurs de gens le
razer laissant sur les ondes sont les
oligarques qui sont proches de zéro et
ça c'est avant la fin de l'année alors
descendre une politique de sanctions
c'est ce que préconise nicolas il y a
d'abord une question qu'on vous pose sur
le site du figaro emmanuel macron at il
raison de répondre aux attaques du
président turc erdogan vous pouvez
répondre vous êtes déjà très nombreux à
avoir répondu si vous n'avez pas encore
répondu on peut le faire ou attendre la
fin de ce débat je vais pose la question
donc à alexandre est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec le point de vue de nicolas
c'est à dire des sanctions à l'encontre
de la turquie
nicole dit il faudrait j'emploie ce
terme virer la turquie de l'otan et
arrêter totalement les discussions sur
l'entrée dans l'ue
oui c'est ça c'est une c'est une
évidence mais c'est pour ça qu'il est
son xoom est la turquie en dehors de
l'otan est évidemment oui on peut pas
avoir un ennemi déclaré de l'occident à
l'intérieur de l'otan qui est censé
défendre l'occident il ya hélas il ya un
paradoxe qui est insoutenable sur ce
plan là nicolas vous êtes d'accord
alors qui va et c'est que la turquie
pose des vrais problèmes à l'automne
notamment par le fait qu'elle a acheté
aussi des systèmes antiaériens russes et
donc elle a déjà une poésie elle a été
exclue du ne s'est pas des petits
systèmes antiaériens c'est des systèmes
qui sont 10 plaisir qu'on peut pas faire
d' attaque aérienne contre la contre la
turquie
enfin en tout cas il faut rester à bonne
distance et cdc des systèmes qui
permettent de ce que d'obtenir ce qu'on
appelle le déni d'accès c'est-à-dire
d'empêcher quelqu'un de devenir sur le
l'espace aérien
ces systèmes sont en cours de test
aujourd'hui donc de toute manière c'est
là aussi où les choses seront peut-être
différent avec bill dann c'est que la
turquie s'est déjà mise en fait en
porte-à-faux vis-à-vis de l'otan et elle
n'a cette position qu'à cause de la
relation personnelle entre trump et là
je crois qu'il ya un mouvement de
d'isolation des états unis qui est pas
nouveau et nous on fait le même coup en
1914 en 1946 sont rarement là tout de
suite quand on a besoin d'eux et donc je
crois que ça changera pas finalement
avec avec joe biden que le le mouvement
de recul des etats-unis qui avait été
déjà amorcée par par obama est poursuivi
avec 30 et sera poursuivi avec baden si
elle est élue mais c'est pas encore fait
loin de là donc je crois que ça nous
pousse à nous organiser
nous même et peut-être que l'europe ne
devrait pas compter uniquement sur le
temps je crois pas à l'idée d'une
défense intégrée parce que ça ne
marchera pas parce que je crois que la
france a encore une arme est
relativement puissantes et il va falloir
que les nations s'organisent pour
pouvoir se défendre elle même il faut la
nature à dissuader à suffire à dissuader
la turquie ne l'ont pas montré cet été
nos noces et en libye c'est pas le c'est
pas de nature parce qu'il faudra du
temps mais je crois que ça ne peut se
faire que par l'impulsion des états
nations aujourd'hui l'europe c'est
l'allemagne et l'allemagne a choisi
d'être otage de son immigration turque
c'est celle la raison pour laquelle
merkel est aussi timide c'est parce
qu'elle a une force que forte communauté
turque en allemagne et que et qu'elle a
peur de de troubles troubles intérieurs
je crois que le président français a
raison parce qu'il va il va s'appuyer
sur les opinions publiques pour faire
évoluer peut-être la position de
l'allemagne et des partenaires européens
c'est comme ça qu'on y arrivera beaucoup
de jus ce que on va avec des mesures
supranationale qui n'arriveront pas
alors j'attends la réponse de nicolas
baverez sur s'appuie également la
réponse sur l'histoire des sanctions
puisque c'était la crise qu imposer tout
à l'heure sur sur la question de
l'europe
brave basse cornouaille après plus d'un
quart de pression et vous avez vous
remets donc il prolonge le débat il est
certain que en fait
et les choses ne sont sont beaucoup
moins manichéenne donc ce qu'il faut
c'est utilisé à la fois le plan national
le plan européen le plan autant si on
peut remettre en route cette alliance
est le plan européen je m'explique je
mets grande europe et très concrètement
phase 1 qu'est ce qu'est ce qui est bien
contraire de gan c'est pas l'europe qui
va livrer des rafales à la grèce c'est
la france c'est la france qui peut le
faire et elle très bien fait de le faire
et ça c'est une arme qui effectivement
est désagréable pour air de gamme parce
qu'il a décimé son armée de l'air
al'inverse si la france veut prendre des
sanctions économiques tout seul contre
la turquie
ça n'a aucun sens elle en souffrir à l
ess et pas efficace donc ça c'est
l'europe et c'est à l'europe de le faire
même chose sur le temps oui le retrait
des états unis il est en route il va se
poursuivre là où il ya une énorme
différence c'est que baye donne lui il a
compris que pour résister
notamment à la chine il a besoin des
alliés et donc il n'est pas dans la
logique de trump qui est cassé l'otan il
est dans l'idée de faire vivre cette
alliance et elle peut être utile
vis-à-vis des russes et vis à vis à vis
des tur cela n'empêche pas que l'otan ne
fera pas tout et que la méditerranée
doit redevenir une c'est notre frontière
sud et il est effectivement impératif
que l'europe retrouve la maîtrise de la
méditerranée parce que c'est la maîtrise
de sa frontière décisives et donc il est
tout à fait temps de le faire c'est
parfaitement dans nos moyens il ne
manque que la volonté on est d'accord
sur l'idée qu'il faut articuler les
différents plans le temps l'europe les
nations même si je poste à force
d'impulsion doit être les nations mais
je me demande moi sur les sanctions
économiques et financières
si l'europe ne réagit pas est ce qu on
attend que l'europe fasse des sanctions
et si elle ne fait pas est ce qu on fait
rien c'est la question alors je
peut-être que ce sera pénalisant dans un
premier temps pour la france mais il
faut y réfléchir et peut-être réfléchir
à avoir les moyens de notre politique
la maîtrise de nos frontières et c'est
pour pouvoir sanctionner la turquie si
son nom sur ce plan là ce que vous
soulevez comme débat c'est quand même la
question du leadership européen jusqu'à
présent c'est un leadership allemand
puisque c'était le deal de 2016
bon aujourd'hui on voit très bien que
l'allemagne en tous les cas c'est ce que
nous dit salim
l'allemagne est très discrète sur cette
affaire et visiblement soit la france
accepte de prendre le leadership et
force l'allemagne soit non mais je pense
que ça mais l'allemagne a bougé elle a
bougé vis-à-vis de la russie après
laffaire navalni y compris sur le
gazoduc nord stream
elle a bougé sur la turquie puisque de
fait en 2016 c'était vraiment un accord
qui avait été conçu il fait par madame
merkel
cette fois ci il ya une condamnation
très claire de la turquie sur la sphère
du haut karabakh et sur les insultes à
emmanuel macron par l'allemagne
donc l'allemagne est en train de train
de manier est en train de bouger qu'on
veut mais qui vient 24 heures après
pourquoi sinon s'il y avait des
sanctions financières de la france à ce
tournoi est forcément contre nous
d'abord elle serait pas très efficace
parce que très franchement la simple
place financière à se prostituer mais
non mais quand on les boycotts sa part
el hamdaoui enfin sauf que pour
l'instant le j'allais dire le marché
turc est beaucoup plus important pour
les entreprises françaises que le marché
français pour les entreprises turques
donc ça j'allais dire ces deux si on
prend les positions y compris de nos
banques de nos assurances regarder
l'importance pour renault de cic les
usines les plus hilarants ventes de
renault en europe
cc unis jean turc quand même et donc si
vous voulez il n'y a pas d'usiné
automobile turc très performante en
france donc il faut quand même que la
nouveauté de toute façon oui c'est pour
ça que la cuc et une réponse européenne
mais s'il ya une réponse européenne
celle là il l'entendra puisque je
rappelle par ailleurs que l'économie
turque est en piteux état et qu'une
partie de l'agressivité extrême d'heures
de gamme s'explique par le fait que son
économie est en train de couler et qu'il
ya quand même beaucoup chez lui de gens
qui se posent la question d'où la
surenchère aussi sur contre l'arménie
sur la méditerranée orientale et contre
la grèce parce que ça c'est la meilleure
manière de refaire de remobiliser à
l'intérieur et y compris de mobiliser
une partie de l'armée qui n'est pas
favorable à l'air de galles mais qui sur
ces thèmes-là le suis parce que c'est
vraiment le coeur du nationalisme turc
alors renault s'il nous dit renault
n'avait pas qu'à des collègues
délocaliser en dehors de l'union
rappelle c'est une autre question des
monsois françois et nous dit l'allemagne
est en train de bouger pour
l'interrogation nous voulons des actes
pas seulement des paroles un tout
dernier point peut-être nicolas quelles
sont aujourd'hui les après je vous
laisse reprendre un peu d'eau pour que
vous reprenez votre voix les produits
français qui sont boycottés c'est une
question que nous posons des internautes
pour la pour l'instant dans ce qu'on a
vu un
il s'est beaucoup les produits
alimentaires donc c'est ça la première
cible c'est ce qui est le plus
spectaculaire parce que c'est dans les
supermarchés et qu'on peut les détruire
donc c'est ça la première cible mais
évidemment ensuite il ya tout ce qu'ils
exportent la france c'est à dire
d'ailleurs c'est ce que vous montrez là
les produits alimentaires sur les
mais il ya le luc il peut y avoir
évidemment aussi ensuite le jour où ça
reprendra le l'aéronautique
et puis le l'automobile un peu tout ou
non tous nos secteurs où on est né veut
plus fort et un moment ensuite le
problème du tourisme se posera aussi
comme et le problème du tourisme là
encore c'est très déséquilibrée c'est à
dire qu'il ya beaucoup plus de touristes
français en turquie qu'il ya deux tu
risques de turquie en france
emmanuel alors il y à regret sauf qu'il
dit il faut également enlevé la caf pour
les ressortissants turcs en france oui
on peut se poser la question de
l'immigration
ne plus accueillir d'immigration turque
renvoyer une partie de des émigrés de
choquer ce congé scolaire sur le
territoire de manière illégale ça peut
être aussi mais là encore une fois ça
suppose que les la france et les moyens
de sa politique c'est-à-dire qu'elles
soient souveraine sur le plan dévoilé le
plan du droit mais elle ne l'est plus
non mais on est parfaitement s'intégrer
mais là je suis pas d'accord avec vous
c'est à dire que les turcs qui sont
présents en france sous un statut légal
et qui se comportent comme des citoyens
normaux qui soient étrangers accueillis
en france ou qu'ils aient acquis la
nationalité française
à partir du moment où est-ce conforme
aux lois de la république et ce soir là
tuez-le hébert et la peinture je ne vois
pas du tout pourquoi on irait leur
demander quoi que ce soit en revanche
effectivement des imams qui clairement
soit font la propagande du régime
d'erdogan soit tiennent des propos qui
sont clairement des propos extrémistes
et avec des appels à la haine
eh bien ces gens là ils ont vocation
effectivement avec elle d'ailleurs il
faut il faut noter et là ça va dans le
bon sens pour la politique des manuels
mâcon moi même si j'ai des doutes qu'on
ait mis tous les moyens sur la lutte
contre l'islamisme je pense que ça
commence parce qu'en réalité la réaction
d'argonne est une réaction au fait cook
très clairement même s'il ne dit pas
qu'on nous qu'on veuille expulsé
certains imams turcs et montre bien
qu'on a encore les moyens d'agir au plan
national
emmanuel macron at il raison de répondre
aux attaques du président turc erdogan
c'était la question qu'on vous posez sur
le site du figaro je regarde la bonne
caméra et vous avez répondu oui quand on
est en tous les cas
vu regarder les réponses à plus de 80% à
84,29 % exactement vous pouvez continuer
à voter jusqu'à au moins demain midi les
chiffres se succèdent les autorités
annoncent un nouveau nombre record de
contaminer alors si vous pestez contre
le couvre-feu je viens parle bien sûr du
sujet dont tout le monde parle c'est à
dire le corona le virus vous risquez de
pester encore quand vous à l'entendre et
7 nous ces nouveaux propos signé ce
matin sur l'antenne de france info du
professeur éric comme là je crois qu'on
a plus le choix
c'est à dire que le virus est tellement
présent parmi nous que là je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a plus le choix il
faut rire confiné un peu comme l'ont
fait les irlandais et les gallois pour
remettre les pendules à l'heure se
permettent de se réorganiser qu' il faut
savoir que plus on attend tard pour
prendre les bonnes décisions
- elles sont efficaces rapides et vous
posterez encore si vous pestez encore
contre le couvre-feu contre ce tweet
d'un confrère célébrant la répression de
buveurs de bière à la terrasse d'un bar
et appelant à une répression plus accrue
personnellement quand j'ai lu ce tweet
j'ai tweeté que j'y voyais qu'on
compense de ce tweet mais en tout cas
une nouvelle illustration de cette
formule de philippe muray sur le désir
de pénal surtout quand j'ai lu il faut
réprimer sans pitié ces comportements
qui propagent le virus
alors pour olivier faure qui comme je
vous le disais tout à l'heure en début
d'émission on n'a rien à voir avec le
patron du ps mais qui est un historien
de la santé qui signe une chronique dans
le figaro de ce lundi à retrouver sur le
figaro.fr s'est historiquement
contreproductif il prend deux exemples
deux exemples historiques puiser dans
les 200 dernières années d'abord une
épidémie de choléra vous savez qu'il y
avait notamment inspiré le très beau
livre est adapté en film de jean giono
le hussard sur le toit on a paniqué et
alimenté la suspicion on penser que le
pouvoir voulait purger la peine le
peuple urbain hostiles au régime
rebelote à la fin du 19e siècle entre
1880 et 1945
la culpabilisation des français
entraînés selon l'historien le refus
d'être dépisté de la tuberculose
et notre historia d'appeler non pas à la
résistance mais au débat c'est donc ce
qu'on fait votre point de vue nicolas
baverez
aujourd'hui tout n'est pas pareil en
europe
c'est quand même une nouvelle fois comme
pour la première vague c'est la france
qui est la plus touchée par cette
deuxième vague et on a quand même pour
une deuxième vague
ben ça je crois que ça c'est
parfaitement clair oui ça c'est pas
contestable et on a quand même un doute
être résident de la république qui le 2
juin avait salué le retour des jours
heureux
la réouverture des bars encensé comme
étant le symbole de l'art de vivre à la
française est donc maintenant on parle
de refermer
donc cette politique du yo-yo elle
montre que en fait chez nous en france
l'exécutif a perdu le contrôle de
l'épidémie il a perdu le contrôle de
l'économie avec la relance il ya aussi
perdu le contrôle de l'ordre public
c'est pour ça que il faudrait qu'on
arrive alors les médecins font de la
surenchère sanitaires les économistes
qu'on entend finalement très peu ne
peuvent finalement que prendre acte des
dégâts et il faut être clair déjà avec
ce qui a été annoncé
l'économie française là elle repart en
récession ce qui veut dire que tous les
chiffres et 8% annoncée de 2 de
croissance en 2021 c'est terminé l'idée
de retrouver le pipe de 2010 2019 même
en 2022 c'est terminé c'est 2023 dans la
meilleure des hypothèses
on a les chômeurs et les pauvres qui
s'accumulent on a également sur le plan
sanitaire d d d opérations qui sont
différées et puis on a aussi une
faillite sur l'ordre public
donc je crois que ça devrait inviter
tout le monde un peu de mesure il faut
être clair ça c'est pas les français qui
en sont le responsable de la question
scène
ce ne sont pas les français qui en sont
responsables donc aujourd'hui quand on
est les françaises ont grosso modo
appliquer ce qui est les messages qu'ils
auront été dit par les hommes et
j'allais dire ils sont mois plus sèche
que les gouvernements etc où les
gouvernants sur un point c'est qu ils
n'ont pas du tout cru que c'était fini
pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut le dire parce
que regarder leur épargne ils ont
épargné 80 milliards ça montre bien que
ça
que c'est pas fini que ça va être long
et difficile les entreprises 160
milliards de liquidités accumulées parce
qu'elles savent très bien que évoqué les
ont intégré le fait qu'il y aurait une
deuxième balle en jetez plus de vous
déprimer non mais c'est l'effet alors
justement donc donc vous vous
culpabilisez pas les français et les
français sont pas responsables de sa
votre point de vue alexandre oui non
plus ce qui est intéressant pour revenir
sur le tweet de revenir sur ce que dit
nicolas il faut quand même éviter que de
comptabilité d'être contaminés comme oui
mais on n'aurait pas dû se mettre dans
cette situation là je le dis depuis le
début il fallait investir massivement
dans la santé on avait six mois pour le
faire en payant bien les gens pour
qu'ils ne ne démissionne pas parce que
ce qu'on est en train de voir c'est
qu'on a peut-être moins de médecins
aujourd'hui qu'on avait au mois de mars
l'année dernière
or en ouvrons d'élus les 136 colline je
pense que c'est la seule solution
rationnelle pour lutter c'est alain qui
nous dit le vrai problème est que le
gouvernement n'a rien fait pour les
hôpitaux pendant six mois moi je pense
que c'est le le vrai problème et on
évolue on a évolué changé et domestiquer
la société on ne peut pas produire
quasiment un changement anthropologique
en quelques mois d'ailleurs je crois que
ce serait pas souhaitable d'aller vers
la société des masques et des écrans et
donc il aurait fallu effectivement
mettre le paquet sur la la santé les
tests et ce terme
non mais je rejoins ce qui est des îles
quand même dans le monde entier on sait
qu' il faut tester tracé isolé soigner
pourquoi est-ce que depuis le printemps
on n'a toujours pas de test groupe est
ce qu'on appelle le pooling on n'a
toujours pas de tests rapides
ça ne s'est pas homologué ça fait des
mois que ça traîne au ministère de la
santé ensuite il faut tracer on a une
application qui est ridicule
elle a été rebaptisée alors elle était
le slogan vide maintenant elle est anti
co-lead celle que c'est la même chose
c'est le même truc ridicule dont on sait
qu'ils ne marchent pas et qu'on continue
méthodiquement au lieu de prendre celles
qui sont peut-être pas parfaite mais qui
marche au moins un peu à l'étranger
isolé il n'ya pas d'isolement en france
et si si vous allez en grèce en italie
et que vous rentrez c'est extrêmement au
sérieux
vous voyez comment ce n'est pas les
personnes âgées aujourd'hui qui sont
quasiment littéralement pardonnez-moi
mais quasiment séquestrait alors les pee
wee mail isolement des malades ça c'est
pas fait du tout vous pouvez rentrer
vous arrivez à l'est les reports
aujourd'hui dans les aéroports français
il n'y a aucun aucun test qui soit faite
alors que normalement
partout ailleurs vous laisser vous
d'abord vous êtes tester ensuite on vous
donne le résultat vous devez laisser un
numéro de téléphone et ensuite si vous
êtes positif vous êtes dans un hôtel
sous vidéosurveillance et vous attendez
la fin
en france si rien de tout ça et sur le
soin ça a été dit pourquoi est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui a toujours que 5800 lits
de réanimation alors la même chose qu'en
mars alors il ya une question qui c'est
ça c'est pas le même sens c'est assez
grave qui est posée par sa ligne sur
youtube est-ce que la capacité d'accueil
en réanimation passe avant l'avenir des
générations futures sur 50 ans est-ce
que ce seule parade à ce seul paramètre
doit constituer l'alpha et l'oméga de la
politique en france
je n'ai pas osé poser la question mais
puisqu'elle est posée non mais c'est la
vraie question est ce que on est
sacrifié ce jeu je pense que nos rations
ça n'aurait pu concilier deux mois c'est
vrai que j'ai du mal à me rends à me
résoudre à ce qu'on trie les gens à
l'hôpital dans un pays développé qui a
une des fonds une dépense publique
record donc j'aimerais bien vivre à des
gens on ne trie pas le nom les très bons
les tripes à mai mais je rende arrête
l'économie pour éviter de trier oui mais
je pense qu'on aurait pu ne pas arrêter
l'économie à investir sur l'hôpital et
ne pas trier les gens maintenant
maintenant le tri des gens doit pas être
pourront répondre à couvrot à la
question je suis patient que ce doit
être l'alpha et l'oméga de la politique
là où pour sauver des gens qui sont
probablement âgé malade on est en train
d'être d'hypothéquer l'avenir du pays
l'avenir de la jeunesse est pas du tout
le fait de pouvoir faire la fête ou pas
faire la fête le soir qui me gêne c'est
qu'on va vers une catastrophe économique
et sociale terrifiante et le triomphe
absolu pour le coup des gaffes à de la
chine une désindustrialisation a cru un
massacre des indépendants qui résistait
encore je pense que c'est ces voix là
c'est une catastrophe qui signe vraiment
un déclin profond de la france et de
l'occident sur l'avoir d'abord
à voir la réplique de nicolas baverez
c'était écrit un livre prémonitoire joue
que je vous conseille même si on en sort
un peu déprimé qui s'appelle la france
qui tombe mais c'est excellent de le
relire encore aujourd'hui même si là-bas
il a quasiment vingt ans maintenant
nicolas les structures sont toujours les
mêmes mais l'accélération et fait du
déclin spectaculaire et spectaculaire et
l'autre l'autre point que je voulais
soulevé avec vous il sait ce que dit
alexandre est ce que ça doit cesser
sinon les sacrifiés et c'est une fausse
opposition
d'abord on trie déjà les gens parce que
quand on explique qu'on des programmes
les opéras center ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'il ya des gens qui
avaient généralement on n'a pas une
opération qui est prévu pour des mesures
de confort donc en fait ça avait été
déjà le cas beaucoup d'heures de la
première vague vraiment des gens qui
auraient dû être payées qui ne l'ont pas
été et dont on a compromis les chances
contrairement à ce qui a été dit donc de
toute façon il ya d'une forme de tri qui
est fêté par ailleurs aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que on sait on l'a vu lors de la
première phase que le confinement
ça entraîne des problèmes sanitaires
majeurs ça entraîne pas que des
problèmes économiques les sa ruine
l'économie on est d'accord mais ça
entraîne des problèmes psychiques et il
ya tout un tas de gens qui arrêtent de
se soigner ça crée un vrai problème de
santé publique et à linverse si on veut
expliquer ce qu'on a vu aux états unis
ou ailleurs
dire qu'on se moque de l'épidémie en
fait l'économie est toujours rattrapé on
l'a vu aussi au royaume uni parce que
évidemment si vous vous laisser libre
champ aux au virus l'économie finit
toujours par être paraître ruiner on l'a
vu aussi au brésil
on l'a vu en inde en inde
or nan c'est un cas d'école l'un d'eux
va faire moins 12% sur le pipe on a des
centaines de honda de l'arrestation
qu'on fasse rien on a de la récession
des questions qu'un meurtre n'est pas
posée il faut une politique raisonnable
qui intègre les deux et c'est quand même
pas c'est quand même pas impossible
d'intégrer les deux c'est à dire d'avoir
une analyse du risque effectivement et
de cibler les gens qui sont les plus et
ensuite surtout 2-2 de mettre en place
ce qu'on a indiqué ce qui n'est pas fait
en france avec cette chose quand même
qui est pas sorcier tester tracé isolé
soignés dans les soins on parle peu du
traitement c'est que on est quand même
polariser sur les vaccins où il faut
attendre quand même au bas mot
ah non pour qu'il ya un vaccin qui est
développé et donc pendant ce temps là on
fait rien oui je pense que c'est
incroyable ça me sidère parce que non
seulement on va très clairement il faut
arrêter de mentir aux gens vers 1 re au
confinement pour deux trois semaines
mais on a le sentiment que dans les
dirigeants nous drake à neupré pas à une
politique du new jusqu'en mai j'entends
jusqu'en septembre là on va vraiment
vers la ruine de nos économies et vers
l'autonomisation de la société ce qui a
dit et tracteurs étaient travail sera
des conséquences sanitaires en plus
d'économique et sociale bien pire que ce
qu'on voit quand est ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui il est tout simplement
anormal que dans un pays qui a le record
mondial de dépenses publiques
on est que ce amélie d'hôpitaux enfin ça
ça parait sert l'argent servait aussi de
parler de pardon mais mais mais il ya
des choses qui n'ont pas été faites
redonner le pouvoir tout simplement au
chef de service ou qos one you ça n'a
pas été fait on continue avec une
bureaucratisation fort et on continue
sur une logique de bercy qui à mon avis
veut faire coûte que coûte des économies
de bouts de chandelles sur l'hôpital et
ça va nous coûter 1000 fois plus cher
ailleurs avec sa part être totalement
paradoxal est idiot c'est quand même une
politique comptable idiote et
contre-productive il faut réorienter le
budget et les ressources sur les
français et la france nous dit arcus guy
la générosité passe après la santé et la
sécurité
c'est la question est votre réponse est
très intéressante en tout cas les
résultats sont très intéressants trouvez
vous que les français sont trop
culpabiliser pour leur comportement face
à la propagation de lakovic 19
et bien tout à l'heure quand on a posé
la question vous était une majorité a
répondu oui et là vous êtes une majorité
à répondre non les français ne sont pas
trop culpabiliser pour leur comportement
face à la propagation de la qualit 19 ça
c'est quand même ça ne signe pas le
désir de pénal bon
[Musique]
dernière question celle qui est posée
par jean rottner le président de la
région grand est qui pas de nécessité de
re confinement locaux est ce que sur le
plan sanitaire
sur le plan économique ça peut avoir du
sens est-ce que c'est réaliste de votre
peau nue c'est très compliqué à mettre
en oeuvre il faudrait vraiment qu'ils
aient une fac et de très bonnes reste
qu'on est en tout cas c'est mieux que en
rang confinement 1re confinement
nationale
donc je pense que s'en aller par exemple
où vous l'avez évoqué il plutôt qu un
recond finement autoritaire des
personnes âgées
en revanche on peut faire passer des
messages pour dire un certain nombre de
gens donc on sait très exposé et qui par
ailleurs pour une bonne part sont sortis
de la vie économique que de fait il vaut
vraiment mieux rester chez soi pendant
une période de temps qui est le la
période qu'on vit en ce moment où la
france s'est effectivement a
complètement perdu le contrôle de de
l'épidémie la dernière chose que je
voudrais dire c'est que il faut d'autant
plus arrêter cette espèce aussi ce
déluge de mesures policières
thiam ans aux données ou la société va
se révolter on l'a vécu avec les gilet
jaune contre par exemple les radars ou
là aussi il voulait sauver des vies
évidemment tout le monde est d'accord
pour sauver des vies mais s'était fait
sans explication de manière extrêmement
autoritaire abrupte et on a une vraie
révolte delà de la société contre le les
attaques contre systématique contre
l'automobile aujourd'hui on peut avoir
la même chose et puis il faut jamais
oublier que il ya une autre protestation
qui peut avoir lieu c'est la
protestation dans les urnes et dans la
politique en regarder et qu' on est
quand même en train de donner des armes
aux populistes de manière de manière
incroyable alors celui qui a écrit sur
les populistes c'est alexandre ii
vecchio où l'on voudrait pas que je
donne le mot de la fin en soi ni colle
non mais le populisme est un symptôme
c'est ce que j'ai fait aujourd'hui et si
le meilleur moyen de
de combattre ce que vous appelez le
populisme et même si moi je pense que
c'est pas la pierre des menaces
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de plus grande
les slams y est cependant à parler le
totalitarisme soft celui des gaffes
acquis en train de et de la technocratie
la technocratie autoritaire à laquelle
on a affaire aujourd'hui me paraît
aujourd'hui une menace aussi grande que
celle des populistes mais passons si on
veut faire effectivement baissé ces
partis qu'on qualifie de populiste la
meilleure solution est effectivement
d'apporter des solutions aux peuples à
la détresse des classes populaires
et effectivement c'est mal parti et non
seulement on n'a pas réussi à résoudre
leurs problèmes liés à la sécurité
culturelle à l'immigration etc à
l'islamisme et ils ont vu alors leur
situation économique les classes
moyennes stagné ces dernières années
effectivement là avec la les mesures
répressives sanitaires et en plus sur
leur faisant porter la culpabilité
c'est peut-être effectivement la goutte
d'eau qui va faire déborder le vase
les nouveaux mondes populiste c'est le
dernier livre 1 d'alexandre ii vecchio
on vous raconte tout les livres de
nicolas baverez également géré par l'est
de la france qui tombe on peut le
retrouver encore aujourd'hui il continue
à y continuer à intéresser certains
lecteurs
et c'est normal parce qu'il est très
très intéressant et les mêmes
passionnant c'est comme cela qu'on a
connu nicolas baverez seach nous dit
qu'il préfère qu'il y ait deux sujets
qu'on explore plutôt que quatre qu'on
survole et bien merci beaucoup vous
voyez on a même dépassé complètement
explosé les temps aujourd'hui je m'en
excuse auprès de l'excellente équipe
menée par julien qu'une aile qui a
permis de la réalisation de ce stream
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivis
merci nicolas marry si alexandre pour ce
débat passionnant vous avez été très
très nombreux à commenter donc vous êtes
toujours là merci beaucoup merci
infiniment de votre fidélité vous restez
sur figaro live nous avons notre
émission rendez vous maintenant dans un
petit peu plus
d'une heure avec nos confrères de la
chaîne parlementaire de public sénat
pour audition publique alors ce n'est
pas olivier du soft qui sera l'invité
qui nous a fait faux bond ce qui est une
mauvaise manière
mais ce sera alexis corbière donc de la
france
insoumise et qui répondra également à
votre question en tout cas je l'airé des
raies en fin d'émission alors à tout à
l'heure sur figaro live et à demain pour
point de vue même heure même endroit
n'oubliez pas le buzz dès demain matin à
9h30 et le taux dont l'invité sera
franck riester a très vite sur figaro
live
[Musique]